Hey, what's going on is bill burr and it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 7th,
2013 the first Monday.
Have a wonderful new year. We're
in our, we're in our teens.
Everybody in this century.
Has Anybody said basically what the uh,
this decade is called, by
the way, is this the teens?
I guess you can officially say that,
right?
I mean they say that about the 19
hundreds, right? They say that. Well,
it was the roaring twenties. They always
blow off the first tooth, the arts,
the teams, the 30s to forties
out of fucking though. Anyways,
yeah, I can believe this shit.
I'm sitting here, right? Wake up.
I don't have anything to talk about
today. Um, so I was like, I know,
I know what I'll do. I'll go check out
the fucking egg heads over@ted.com.
See what the fuck they are
up to and what do I see?
This is why we're going to be extinct
quicker than global warming or click
quicker than anything else
you could ever come up with.
One of the things right on the front
page is this guy, Hayden Perry,
and you know what he's
talking about everybody,
he's talking about reengineering
mosquitoes to fight disease.
How can these people be so smart and
so fucking stupid all at the same time?
Did you really think that you're just
going to reengineer like I don't know what
they're going to do.
Like take the old engine
out and put something better
in there that works for us.
The guy starts it off, of
course is always with, you know,
something really ominous. He's
like, and forgive my awful whatever,
British accent here,
but he comes out and he's just like,
today we're going to talk about,
okay,
the most dangerous animal
on the planet for humans.
Now most of you probably think that
that's Togare. Maybe it's a lie,
and I'm actually talking
about the mosquito.
The mosquito has killed more people than
plagues war aids and he goes on this
whole fucking thing.
Okay?
And he's going on and on about how
mosquitoes have killed a bunch of fucking
people, you know, throughout
the course of history,
which if you fucking think about it
is it's really not that mind blowing.
You know, plagues come and
go, wars begin and end,
but mosquitoes,
they never quit every fucking day.
Their bite and people,
you know what I mean?
They liked that dude that
always goes to the gym.
He doesn't take six months off and eating
fucking moon pies and then come back
with this big doughy stomach like me,
the fucking mosquito.
Okay.
Is relentless. All right? So then he's
just sitting there going, now you know,
the mosquito,
it only travels only 200 yards and its
entire fucking life and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. But basically it
lays eggs and shit, you know,
water and that type of crap. And
then, you know, we're assholes.
We go all over the fucking world and
we've got the eggs with us and exceed all
the mosquitoes are all over the fucking
planet as they should be biting people,
killing people,
giving us some fucking elbow room.
This fucking jackass in his
fucking egg head friends.
Once a re-engineer,
one of the few things that is keeping
the human population just vaguely in
check,
which it isn't.
We're up to 7 billion people in this
fucking asshole wants to reengineer
mosquitoes to fight disease
rather than to spread it.
Do you understand how fucked up this guy
is? Like it's like a form of terrorism.
I don't know. I know you
guys sick. I'm a moron,
but like there's a reason
why mosquitoes kill people.
You know there's a reason.
There's a reason.
Everything kind of kills everybody
into it. He keeps it balanced.
This fucking jerk off.
Do you really think you just going to
rewire these fucking mosquitoes and then
that's going to, that's not going
to have a domino effect thing.
Okay.
You know what it's like.
Listen to these fucking guys.
It's like listening to some
weekend warrior who decides
he's going to rewire his
house and you know,
within three years he's going to fucking
burn it down because he doesn't have,
he's, he's not a licensed electrician.
That's what these guys are.
Okay. This is so fucking smart.
They're going to reengineer a mosquito,
but like how, how's that going to
affect the fucking God give me up.
Giving me an animal, a bird. I don't
fucking, it's going to affect something.
I'm so in over my head over this, but
I know I'm right. I know I'm right.
You can't just, you can't just, if
you fucking re-engineer that thing
to help us, okay. It won't,
not now it can't kill us.
Let's talk about this.
This uh,
the fuck did he call it Dang gay disease
[inaudible] disease or some shit that
evidently is killing a bunch of people.
First Time you get it,
you feel like you have a fever and you
could actually have the feeling like your
bones are going to break the ECC,
call it breakbone fever and a,
you develop like antibodies,
but there's three strains and then when
you get the next one, I mean it just,
it's, it's like a horror
movie, but a necessary one.
You know,
these fucking nerds every
think that there's a reason
that mosquitoes kill people.
That's what I,
I love about nature is it all makes sense.
You know,
if you just remove your emotions from it
and you just look at the whole thing is
like, uh, I dunno like a math problem. No,
G Asia, right? Where where
we have you got way too much.
It's like you'd be open the cupboard,
you know what I mean?
You'd get half like fucking
like one fig Newton and then
7 billion pounds of flour.
I think that they should not,
not re-engineered.
They just let the fucking mosquitoes
kill people. And if you get killed,
I'm sorry, you know, but you're dead.
It's over. You're out of the way.
And we continue on and his
apples for everybody, you know,
we're already growing salmon and dishes.
Manmade fucking salmon were literally
fucking with the food supply,
another form of terrorism. So he just
comes in and poisons the food supply.
You know, if you have like
a fucking mask on, you know,
in some sort of a bath towel on you,
on your head or whatever,
then it's all, yeah, it's a
terrorist, that's a terrorist.
But if you've got a fucking lab coat on,
okay?
You know, you putting all these pesticides
in there and that type item. Fuck it.
I'm on, I'm on. I'm on my
soapbox is sweet people.
Yeah.
Standing up on that box. Letting
everybody here. My ignorance.
Hayden Perry,
if for some reason,
I don't know why you felt like being dumb
this week and you're listening to this
podcast,
can you please not [inaudible] can you
and your friends please not reengineer
mosquitoes? Can you just let
them do their fucking yeah
job yet.
Oh,
why don't you do the world a favor and
stick your head in a mosquito nests.
Why don't you fucking do that?
This is like mad scientist shit.
ted.com is the scariest fucking website
out there. These fucking assholes,
you know,
on the reengineering
mosquitoes and they're building
robots that know everything
that can run like Barry
Sanders, you know, and like,
like that's not going to be a bad thing.
Hayden Perry.
Okay.
You know what is his heart is in
the right place. He sees death,
he sees suffering, he sees pain
and he wants to fucking stop it.
All right?
Because what he's doing is he's chasing
the myth of a utopia.
The myth of Utopia is that
if you lived in a utopia,
everybody would be happy all the time
and nothing bad would ever happen.
And that's just not the case
because of the emotion of boredom.
If everything was awesome
all the fucking time,
you would go out of your fucking mind
because every day would be the exact same.
It would just be awesome. Hey, it's
lunch time. You have a Turkey sandwich.
Isn't this the greatest Dirk?
He said, yeah, it's every day.
It's the greatest fucking sandwich ever.
Every fucking day.
Exhausted with happiness.
It would be exhausting.
You know what I mean?
You gotta have people getting
bit by mosquitoes dying.
If that doesn't happen, you can't
enjoy the Superbowl at the same level.
You know what I mean?
You can't enjoy just sitting there
having a Turkey sandwich cause you can't,
you don't have the thing to be like, well
at least you know I a Turkey Sandwich,
the meat's a little dry.
But Hey,
at least I didn't get beat bit by
fucking mosquito and die, you know,
laid face down in a puddle.
Eggs.
Yeah.
Do you eliminate all of
that? I mean, I don't, well,
what did what he's supposed to fucking do.
Yeah.
There's all these, these, all these,
there's all these myths that if we
just did this, people would get along.
If we just did that, people get
along. I don't think we would.
I think boredom.
Boredom is at the basis of, of, I
don't know that that's what drives us.
I Dunno. We just want to do something
else. Can Be in competitive and all it is.
You wouldn't get rid of that.
Just imagine that if you
lived in a fucking utopia,
everybody had the best car.
Everybody drives a fucking
Bentley. Everybody's got
the greatest fucking stereo.
Everybody's got up Victoria secret
fucking model. Everybody's got, you know,
I don't an infinity pool.
Everybody's got it.
Okay. Now that if he could just snap
your fingers and make that happen,
that would be probably the most insane
five days straight party the world has
ever seen.
Yeah.
But after five fucking days you,
you'd get, you'd get sick of it.
I think you would.
Nobody ever stubs their toe. There'll
be ever falls down. You just, you know,
I don't know.
Re-Engineering fucker mosquitoes.
Okay.
Do you know I saw a transvestite do a
fucking face plant this week and it coming
out of a doughnut shop.
First of all, in La there's
doughnut shops. I swear to God,
there's like 19 chains of, of,
of doughnut shops out here.
They're on like every other block.
I don't get it.
Everybody out here that I know is in
this business and you're trying to stay
remotely and shaped so you,
you limit your fucking Twitter bashing.
Although the,
the level that you get bashed on Twitter.
I Dunno who's eaten all
the fucking donors who, um,
but they were everywhere.
So
I'm fucking cutting down. Uh, oh
man. I was on, I was on Fountain Nav.
I really shouldn't give the straight up,
but fountain have is,
is the one for you tourists out here when
you want to go east to west or west to
east and it's during rush hour. Don't
take, don't take fucking sunset.
Don't take Santa Monica. Take
Fountain. It's right in the middle,
but I'm one of those strips there.
There's this place, uh, yum,
yum donuts I believe is what it's called.
Or is that Santa Maria?
I can't remember.
Okay.
So anyways, so fucking doughnut shop
and they got this stupid little like,
okay,
you don't like those j you don't
like to put like Paul's down.
And then they tie a chain to it,
those little things and kind of droops
down and goes over to this fucking dude
woman.
Right.
Was stepping over it and it had a thing
of donuts and just fell down on the
ground.
Now normally I would laugh.
The guy in a dress fell face first
with a fucking handful of donuts.
I mean,
that's pretty much you're going right
down the checklist of a home run when it
comes to comedy. But the
dude fell, so a femininely,
I felt bad. The gentleman
in me was like, oh,
that lady guy,
the lady just fell.
And the way the dude put his hand up,
it was just,
it ended up just being really sad.
You know, but I, I pride myself.
I'll pat myself on the back here,
me and my ego that I resisted
the urge of taking out my phone,
phone and filming it. You know, I
don't, I don't like that shit. Now,
how every fucking moment becomes this.
Uh,
I don't know what to call it.
I don't like how a humiliation never ends.
Now,
you know,
these poor kids coming up,
it's just like somebody gets kicked in
the balls that get shot with a fucking BB
gun in his dick.
Somebody films it.
O m g epic failed Dick BB fucking video
and then it's just on the internet
forever.
And the guy's 35 years old.
He's got a drinking problem
and he's looking at this girl.
He feels sparks for the
first time in years.
He goes to talk to her and right as things
that go and good, somebody yells at,
hey, did that fucking epic
fail Dick BB Guy? Yay.
He's like, oh my God. Is
that you? I remember that.
Okay.
Then a chunk of your helmet get
taken off. What the fuck? Right?
It just never know. Humiliation,
humiliation never ends. Never fucking has,
I don't even know what I'm
talking about this week.
Okay.
Does it matter?
I don't think it matters this week.
Cause Hayden Perry is going to reinjure
mosquitoes to fight disease. Okay?
You're going to rewire them and you're
going to rewire everything else on the
fucking planet.
So it's all compatible.
Are you just going to
fuck with that Hayden?
[inaudible]
I don't get it. You know
what it is? This guy,
I don't even think he fucking believes
in it. He is, he, I bet corporate owned,
he's corporate owned.
This is what they're gonna do.
They're gonna own the
re-engineered mosquitoes. Okay.
And then when they bite you, they make
you stronger. And uh, then they also,
they go out and they choke out
all the other bits. Mosquitoes.
But you can only get them from them.
And then what they do on the backside is
they make the regular ones that aren't
re-engineered. They re-injured near them
to make them even more lethal. Alright?
Cause that way either the
way mosquitoes reproduce,
it's just like this Endress
and everybody's going to
want to buy your mosquitoes.
You know,
and I'll be this endless supply and an
endless demand for the supply that you
could just fucking there.
They're like rabbits,
right?
It's a salt.
Makes sense to me.
The fuck my 15 minutes and Jesus
is getting deep this week. Um, all
still a little advertising
here and they'll tell you
about story about a rabbit.
I think it's going to be all animals
this week. Um, the fuck is it?
[inaudible] all right.
Um,
stamps.com everybody a one great
resolution you can make for this new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to
do that with stamps.com.
Think about how much time you've wasted.
Go into the post office or how much
money you've wasted leasing and expensive
postage meter a stamps.com is the,
is the better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your own computer and your printer to
buy and print official US postage for any
letter or package with
stamps.com everything you
would do at the post office you
can do right from your own desk.
And at a fraction of the
cost of a postage meter. Um,
I've used stamps.com for the last, I
dunno, when did I start reading these?
About a year ago,
about a year ago,
I sent all my DVDs out to the clubs.
It's phenomenal.
I used to have to go down to the post
office or go to one of those mailboxes
cetera. Standing there with
these two big stupid boxes.
Actually three wondering if I
was going to come home with one,
trying to do the math, standing
in line behind some lady, right?
I don't have to do that anymore. I just
grab a box, bing, bang, boom. Put It on,
put it on the scale and I'm done.
Right now.
Get this special offer when you use my
last name Berbee you are for a no risk
trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a
digital scale and up to $55 free postage,
55 bucks right in your pocket to
begin the new year. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarburrthatstamps.com
enter
birth. All right, back to the podcast. So
last night I'm doing this standup show.
I'm doing a show where I stand up and um,
you know, I'm trying to find
a parking spot and I do,
I'm going to take to through every like
minute fucking painful detail of this.
You know,
I put it in reverse.
I look in the camera and I realize
I'm a little bit in the red,
so I pull it up a little bit,
but then there's a Mustang in front of
me and old one looks like a 67 or 68.
And I'm like, wow, I want this guy
to feel like I don't respect his car.
So I backed up a little bit more realizing
that I'm mostly in the unpainted area,
so I guess legally I'm okay.
So then I decided to get out
the driver's side door. Okay.
I lead with my left leg rather than
swinging my right over. I'm sorry.
I get out of the fucking car
and I'm walking up the street.
You don't trying to think what I'm going
to talk about when I go on stage and I
look over and there's this fucking
rabbit sitting outside this apartment,
a rabbit. And this isn't a wild
rabbit. This is a domesticated rabbit.
What do I know?
Because it's not afraid of me.
It's just sitting there looking at me
like, you know, hey, what's going on?
Like it's just chilling on the porch
and it's fat to fat fucking rabbit.
Like, you know, it's eating human food
rather than, uh, the held rabbits eat.
What are these eight carrots?
Least the cartoon wants to do the carrots,
carrots in the wild
lettuce grass.
I don't know what the fuck they eat.
Squirrels.
I bet they'll find that out
one day that they actually,
every once in a while eat
squirrels. Like, you know,
for the longest time when they thought
like chimpanzees were vegetarians and
then they found out that every once in a
while they go on a hunt and they kill a
monkey fucking chimpanzees. I hate him.
I hate those motherfuckers.
Okay,
fuck mosquitoes or you bite me and I
get a fever and I get a rash and I feel
like my bones are going to break. And then
I, you know, I'm hot, I'm cold, I'm hot,
I'm dead. It's over. All right.
I would much rather have that than
to have some fucking roided out.
Fireplug jump on me. Rip My face off,
pulled my nuts off and twist my foot off.
I would much rather, even though
I'm going to bleed out quicker,
they're going through the hell of the
Denki death. Whatever the fuck it is.
I would rather go through that.
Oh my God.
Those fucking creepy long chimp fingers.
Okay.
You know,
fucking grab and right under your chin,
like you're some mass wrestler and
he's going to reveal your identity.
Just fucking rip shit.
God damn face back.
Oh my God. Oh Shit. I forgot this.
I forgot this. I got to look
this up right now. You know what?
I was in New Mexico recently,
um,
visiting a high school friend and uh,
hang on a second.
The fuck was her name and I was in this,
okay.
This restaurant.
Okay.
What is it?
Bronco boozer.
I can't remember a fucking name.
God dammit. Bill, you stank.
I'm in this Italian restaurant, right?
And they've got all these fucking, uh,
there it is.
Gina Bronco Boozer.
So they've got all these Italians
on the wall, like the old ones.
You've always heard Frank Sinatra and
all the old Tito point day, you know,
all the big Italian Theda plant.
He's Latino. I don't give a fuck. Um,
all the classic ones you've heard of.
Um,
it was a girl there was
staring at the other girl.
She was trying to be the hot whore and
then the other girls whore tits were
hanging out even more. And she's
giving them a Seigel Sophia Loren.
Yeah.
So feel a rant, you know, all these
Italians, right. Beautiful people. Right.
And then they just had
some, uh, uh, obscure ones.
Yeah.
So I see one,
and it's,
it's this woman in tight inner her knee,
her name is Gina Bronco,
a boozer.
And I start reading the story
and basically she was a female wrestler,
hugely fucking popular.
And uh,
her big thing was how she got into
wrestling. She was like five foot five,
like 210 pounds. Okay, we're
talking fourth and goal here.
Low Center of gravity.
She puts that show Ironhead
Heyward with the pussy. Okay.
It's disgusting, but
it's true. So anyways,
her big claim to fame was that she choked
a fucking cow to death with the thighs.
Now to me that just sounds like
some Vaudeville likes step right up.
Step right up. So you know
what, back to jump that,
that with the ties and you've got to buy.
But one minute we will give you this
Advil or whatever the fuck you one back
then. Um, but anyways, that was
her claim to fame to get into, uh,
into wrestling.
So she went around barnstorming around
the country and she won all these matches.
If she became hugely popular,
big time fan favorite,
and she would do all these
benefits for charity and whatnot.
So one day, this is how little
we knew about animals back then,
they decide to raise money for charity
that they would have Gino Bronco Booza
wrestle in,
old baboons from the zoo
to old toothless backbone.
If this didn't have its teeth. And if
you haven't seen anything on baboons,
like baboons,
have teeth like a fucking lion.
There were ever one Jaan.
You can just stop staring at their
rainbow book club ass and just look at it.
It's fucking teeth. I mean,
this thing could literally
bite your fucking head off,
but the Babel was old and it didn't
have any teeth. What could go wrong?
So they bring the fucking baboons down.
I don't know if that had little silk
wardrobe or we're in a robe like fucking
Greg the Hammer Valentine. Who knows?
I don't know what had happened.
Maybe it had his monkey hair all
fucking slicked back and died. Platinum.
I Dunno what, what? It's gonna but
gene is going to wrestle this sinks.
A gene is already in the fucking ring.
This whole stories is on
the wall at the restaurant.
I can't believe I didn't take a picture
of it because it's really very little
about this on the Internet.
So
she's fucking waiting.
They'd take a banana.
They put her on the stool in the rink.
Okay. Now the month, the baboons,
old toothless baboons in the ring with
this gene of Bronco Boozer Bouz A,
if you're trying to look it up and I
don't know what happened. She starts,
I don't know, made some sort of aggressive
move towards the fucking baboons.
The baboons jumps on her and just snaps
her neck and she's dead within the first
fucking five seconds of the match.
And the promoter was like, Oh hey god,
he freak it out saying
something ridiculous like, um,
basically how would I know
that that would have happened?
How would you know that that
would have happened? Well, well,
baboons have the strength of
like, what five men, you know,
and I don't know if you've noticed
baboons don't really like, you know,
you don't ring a bell and then they stop.
That's the end of the round.
Bafo you know, they, if you
start tapping out like, oh yeah,
all right.
You know, cause it's turning
your head around. Huh?
You know, it does not stop it. You
can't tap out with the baboons.
Baboons do not have a fucking where
that 10 minute time limit dose.
They don't fight like that. They
have a fight to the death. All right?
You're coming in there trying
to raise money for emphysema.
That things coming in. They're like,
all right, fucking blood sport here.
I don't have any teeth.
What's the next thing I'm doing?
I'm going to fucking turn your
head around like the extra seats,
even though I never saw the movie.
And even if I did,
I don't even know if it would register,
you know?
Okay.
Do Bet Cheetahs are afraid
or afraid of baboons.
The baboons comes over like,
get the fuck out of my territory.
Cheetahs for the most part I like,
or leopards,
maybe it's even a leopard
and even bigger cat.
I Dunno what I dunno,
but um,
I will tell you to look up the
story of Gina Bronco Boozer,
but there's really nothing on here
other than in that restaurant.
And they kind of had
the whole fucking story.
If I ever go out to New Mexico again,
I'm going to go to,
it's an Italian restaurant or is if
somebody lives out there, Jesus Christ,
why don't you use technology?
Please take a picture of the story.
It's on the wall and please send it to
me and we'll put it up on the podcast
page because it's fucking unreal. You
know what's funny? It was one, I read it.
All I thought about was this is like,
this is something like fucking Joe Rogan.
You know,
I should have sent the story to him.
He could have done a
fucking hour of this on,
on his podcast with all his knowledge
of animals and ultimate fighting.
Who the fuck we're
getting to a goddamn rig.
Who the fuck would get into a ring with
a, with a baboons and like, I guess,
you know, they're really,
there was no discovery channel.
Okay.
And that's the honest thing.
Like I wouldn't know anything about,
I would know anything about baboons if
it wasn't for basic cable, you know?
And I wouldn't have known that that woman
got her face fucking ripped off if it
wasn't for, you know, the instant
new shit. I wouldn't know anything.
All I would know about would be the guy
up the street with fucking seven toes.
I would just know that country shit. But
anyways, if you get a chance, you know,
look it up, there isn't much information
on it. But um, so there you go.
It's been all about animals so far hasn't
it? The animal podcasts. Oh. Anyway,
so I'm sitting there looking at this
fat fucking rabbit and it's just sitting
there and it was nighttime.
I,
it really disturbed me the
way it was just sitting there,
not looking out for coyotes,
not looking out for a cath.
I actually played out in my head this
awful scenario of a cat slowly coming up
to it's stocking it.
You know,
when the rabbit looking right at the cat
and the cat having this weird sort of,
this motherfucker sees me, doesn't he?
You know, the lovely Nia, everybody.
So I'm telling this story.
I saw this rabbit sitting outside a
house last night or house rabbit of fat.
I've been eating fruit loops at
the dining room table, house wrap.
And it just really disturbed me
because it didn't know any better.
It didn't know to be scared.
It wasn't scared of me.
It wasn't looking to Reno fucking yes,
that's what I'm saying.
It's domestic. And what'd you come
down here to get on the podcast? Maybe,
but grab yourself a microphone there,
lady. You got to plug yourself in.
So anyways, I uh, the chords are
over there. We've been through this.
I'd hit pause in this thing,
but I don't know how to do it.
And it always ends up shutting off and
then I have to splice it together and
then something happens where, uh, I dunno.
So anyways, hey, you
guys, have you ever, uh,
you ever go to make a pot roast in a Dutch
oven and in the middle of it you just
start drinking beers and you're about
four beers in and you can't remember what
time you put the pot roast dinner.
That's what the fuck I did yesterday.
So embarrassed I made it. I made
a tough pot roast. Here we go,
and she's putting on the windscreen.
Everybody a head. Bam. She's in.
She's in. Hello. Hey.
Did you try any of the pot roast
or are you still on your diet?
I did try some pot rose,
but I am still on my diet even though
Paul Ross wasn't a fall off a little bit
and back on it for the next,
well for a while, but yeah,
in the middle of the pot roast,
it tasted our right. Right.
The outside got a little tough.
Yeah.
Well that's what you get for and you know,
I don't understand why people want people
cook these beautiful meals that you've
been cooking lately and they have been
beautiful meals. My Ngo, you know? Yeah.
You have a nice glass of wine.
It's like the whole process.
Nobody's slams for Budweiser's in a row
while making these beautiful restaurant
quality meals. That's a
whole, yeah. You know what?
It was stumbling around the kitchen
like, Ooh, done. Do they put it in? Oh,
I fucked it up. Oh, it turned the wrong
burner. I did that. I was supposed to
turn up the heat for the
potatoes and I had the, uh,
the roast on simmer and I turned up the,
the roast one high.
And I'm sitting there like,
why isn't this these fucking potatoes?
It's doesn't even look
like it's getting hot.
And then all of a sudden I
heard my, uh, my au jus sauce.
Huge bubbling over there. Yeah.
The whole thing. Well, you know
what, it was my OCD kicked in.
I had all those Budweiser's leftover
from the Rose Bowl and uh, I,
they're just taking up space.
You don't have OCD, you have
add. I like that. You're like,
oh, I have OCD. Why I had to drink all
those beans. Well, let me
explain it. A compulsive,
this is why a sense of in Santa
Barbara sets of compulsive drinking.
Now listen stands for
a disorder. Let's, hey,
whoa.
No, I, I had the, uh, I
just, we had like fucking 12.
We brought so much beer. I had
like 15 Budweiser's in there. Okay.
It's taken up all that space. So I'm
thinking if I drink one a day, you know,
I'll knock this out in half a
month. Then I go, what if I have to?
I knock it out [inaudible] seven
and then I was just like, you know,
I had them in stacks or two
and I was just like, you know,
I knocked out two and then I
had my third one and I'm like,
well the other one's still sitting
there taking up that space.
So knock that one out. You could
have put them on the bottom shelf.
Like way in the back though. There's,
there's ways you could have, I could've,
I could've bought a bigger fridge.
We could've bought a bigger fridge.
Rosebowl was awesome to share.
We did have a tragedy though,
and I can't name the name,
but somebody got a little too drunk,
was walking towards the street.
I don't have,
what always happens every year is
we get absolutely fucking hammered.
And then we all just,
all of a sudden we just notice where
the only ones in the parking lot,
and then that's when it clicks that the
game's about ready to start. So then we,
or the golf course, which is
the parking lot, and we, um,
we just walk into the stadium sort of
together and then get separated and then
come back together again, like a band
that worked out its differences, you know?
And when we got to our seats,
only three of us made it and
there was some other guy, no,
I remember what's his face was saying,
yes, someone's so lost his ticket.
I like get the fuck Outta here.
And they didn't get in.
And then some other Douche bag comes
up and sits in my buddy seat where like
three drunk Agri guys. What the fuck do
you get that Dick? And he's like, oh,
I bought it.
Yeah.
But at first he said he
bought it for 25 bucks.
Then they told somebody
else he bought it for 50.
Either pickpocket that thing or
he founded on the fucking ground.
But at the end of the day it's um, you
know, it's all my buddy got too hammered.
That's why I always buy the ticket
holder every year. It's like,
you know when you put a toddler on a
leash, so can't run away from you. That's,
that's what I do. I put the ticket
in there, put it around my neck,
and then I commence drinking like I'm
still in college so it just stays there.
Stays there. You don't have a problem.
Feel your neck. Get and tugged,
you know somebody trying to
steal it. Right. You know,
you can even put it like underneath your
shirt if you're worried about people
you know, getting funny ideas. Yeah, but
I'd get so drunk I would think I lost it.
I'd be like,
where is it?
I can't breathe.
It's the way we know.
We had a great time though.
You were getting jealous when you saw
all that food that we were cooking.
Fucking lie ahead. Did the, did
the ribs up throw down like it's,
it's some sort of like food
tailgating, competition, you know,
it's like this.
Did you tell them,
did you tell your podcast
listeners what was on the menu?
This extensive tailgating menu? Oh,
we had a short ribs. Wait, wait,
start at the beginning. What
is the beginning? Right?
9,000 fucking Budweiser's. Oh, we
had breakfast with a lamb sausage.
We got this great what
Ya and my neighborhood.
So we went over there and literally put
in an order that we had to pick up two
days later. A lot of animals
died on this day. People,
we had lamb.
You are very organized about it.
It's not like you just went to Ralph's
and just grabbed a bunch of sheep meat.
Like you went to the butcher,
the basket.
Pretty much the only butcher and our
neighborhood and put an order as he had
lamb sausage, goat cheese
and rose fat bar. Yeah.
Um, all right. So that
was breakfast. Okay.
And that's the greatest Omelet I
have every year. Yeah. Sitting there,
I got a rose bowl ticket around
my neck and on my beer in my hand.
Exactly.
An omelet in my mouth.
I know all that guy shit that it's
just lampooned now it gets just fucking
considered silly. If you enjoy
that, like this is America. It is.
It's fucking great.
And until you've had a fucking omelet on
New Year's Day on a golf course outside
the Rosebowl go fuck yourself. It was
a tremendous, and then what's his face?
We had a, we had Coby beef, hot dogs.
What's, I just found out Coby beef.
The reason why it's so soft
as they treat it like veal.
So I've gotta be done with that shit
now. Oh, so now you're not gonna,
you're not going eat that anymore cause
you're very, you're anti veal. So yeah,
I don't mind fucking just walking up
to a cow and blown his brains out.
That's, I don't, that's part
of nature. Somebody got ya.
That's all right.
But to stick him in a fucking
cage and so they can't move.
So the meats more tender to just
torture it like that, you know?
Okay. Yeah. I mean that's,
it's, it's, it's unnecessary.
It already tastes delicious.
It's doing the fucking job. It's filling
up my belly, you know, let it walk around.
Can you let her walk around? Um, whatever.
And then we had the ribs, we had the
ribs and a, with his fucking, his,
his rub in the mop. And it
was just, it was the shit.
And then what had the mini apple pies
baked by you and then they my little pie
face and then uh,
we got the best compliment.
We heard people next to us were
sprint. Go and see, look at it.
They're doing it right. They got pies. And
you're like, that's right motherfucker.
I know who brings individual Pi.
We used to read that whole game.
I used to back in the day when I
used to go to the Patriots Games,
when I had season tickets in 1989,
we used to fucking show up with a keg
of beer and a bag of chips and we'd be
sitting there.
I don't know those people that are doing
it right and we just get absolutely
annihilate every year that I
swear to God that's, that's,
that's accurate. We would,
we would have a half barrel.
We had a half barrel beer and we would
be doing keg stands because we were
morons. Literally like counting,
why do I ain't doing that shit?
Is All these adults were looking
at us like summer were repulsed.
And then there was other people who
did that when they were our age.
So they would just sitting
there with half a smirk,
probably betting which one of us
was going to puke first. Yeah,
I did one time puking after a keg.
Stan is the most refreshing way
ever to puke. I've never done it.
Kegs stand before. It's so it's
so cold when it comes back out.
Usually when you heal.
Well I guess a keg stand usually is
you're supposed to do like somebody holds
you up upside down drinking. Okay.
And what, so we weren't doing that.
We weren't doing that.
What's the point of being upside down
is that you get more fucked up that way?
Cause they're all disoriented.
No,
it's one of those things where you're
young and you think, if I'm drinking beer,
I'm crazy. I'm away from my parents.
What could make this crazier?
What if I did it upside
down? Yeah, it's stupid.
It's just suburban. Do Sheree. So I
actually, I actually never did that. Uh,
we, we did a more adult
version of cake cake Stan,
which is basically you just fucking,
you turn the tap on and you just,
and we were timing it. It was like the
Olympic trials of beer drinking and,
and as you puked you are out or if he
just tapped out like I can't do it,
seed start off with 10 seconds
and it was completely inaccurate.
If you would just be going
one, two, three, four,
five right all the way up to 10 and if
you made it to 10 you in the next round
and then went up to 20 then it went up
to 30 then we're up to 40 and you've got
to think, you've already
drank for 10 seconds. St Drank
for 20, that's 30 seconds.
Now you drink for 39 he drinks 60 and
it just keeps going and going and going.
And we got all the way up. One time where
I was trying to beat this guy and I,
and I didn't have a reputation for being
able to drink and I just went into this
fucking zone and I went head to head
with this guy and I just kept making,
it was like the Cinderella team going
through March madness and somehow I made
it,
I made it to the championship game.
It was me against this other guy
who had like a fucking iron stomach.
And um,
I ended up,
I ended up losing is what I did,
but it was one of the great pukes in
my life because it was just ice cold.
It was like reverse drinking a glass
of water, ice cold glass, you know, ed,
a Puke, it's like acidy and it
tears up your throat. It wasn't,
it was just like, it just came
out. Was this in high school?
I know I was, well, I would think I was
in my fifth year of college by then.
Now I'll leave it out of college.
I was 21 when I did that.
So I should have been a junior, but I
was still a freshman. Yeah. And I tried,
I drank beer and high school only
because I don't drink beer now as you now
cause I don't like the taste of it,
but I drank it in high school because
you know that's what you're trying. Oh,
that's my running joke with you.
I school,
I think you'd like this one and I
always make sure it's the most hoppy
discussing it. So rude. You
know how much I don't like
beer. I just, but yeah, I use,
I would drink it in high school because
that's what people were when you would
drink in high school. But then I got onto
the, uh, the Boone's farm there, you know,
that cheap little strawberry wine
and wine coolers. What is it called?
Boone's farm. It's a kind of um,
wine. It's like really sweet.
Really cheap. Yeah. You get it.
I like the gas station. We would,
we would send them hang over. We,
we, yeah, we would send it, you know,
like one of the cuter girls,
um,
to go in there and just kind of like
smile and just walk up with a couple of
bottles of the Boone's Barb.
And you know,
the 19 year old or whatever kid behind
or just let her buy it and not check your
Id. Cause she's hot. She's cute,
right? Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
Why fuck everybody. I mean I'm
not, I'm not condoning that.
I'm jealous, but I
would, I always hated it,
but I just did it because
that's what you did.
You know I'm jealous of that is what it
is guys. You know, on a certain level,
you're fucking resent that.
Yeah.
Because we don't have the option of
being hot and cute and just getting
something just coming like hat tea.
He had like a case of beer playing
with your nonexistent pigtail or maybe
you're, you're a Steven Seagal
ponytail. Just sort of twisting around.
It is a weird visual. Let's read
some fucking emails for the week. Um,
Pakistani cricket fan. He said,
all right man, this isn't,
this is important. First
podcast of 2003. Right.
All right, sorry about that. I fucked the
thing up. I didn't delete last week's,
I gotta get a memory card that has
a little more memory on it anyways.
Oh Jesus. What is this now? All right.
It's just gone off the rails here.
Alright.
Pakistani cricket fan starting over
again. All right, man. This is important.
First podcast of 2013. Right?
This is about cricket, the sport.
Don't you stop here now come
on and bear with me. Okay,
so Pakistan and India just had a
cricket series. Now these two guys,
they don't like each other, right? Why
don't they like each other? I don't know.
I'll be completely honest. You just
got fuck. You were like, right.
I thought you like you knew the answer.
Now I don't lay down and I'm not, uh,
not well versed in that I had made.
All right. It's not my students,
the usual shit. They live
near each other. All right.
Familiarity breeds contempt and
they fight over cashmere much.
You have a few years ago they will like,
I'm gonna fucking Nokia and the
other guys like, go ahead and tow it.
We got the bomb toe. You
don't remember that? No.
Maybe that was a movie I saw anyways.
So Pakistan,
India just had a cricket series.
We, our arch rivals and shit.
Not only in cricket button,
everything.
I mean we had the biggest
tank wars in Shit did you?
They should make a movie about that and
have like Tan white people play you guys
and then you guys can get
offended. Um, so had this,
these fucking commercials in which the
voice said Pakistan is coming to India
and they're faggot cricket
player. Ooh. We're like,
oh, he's saying, I
thought they were saying,
I thought they were saying that in the
commercial. I was like, wow, no, this,
this gentleman is, he's using it
all right. Sorry. I'm sorry. Okay.
And which the voice said Pakistan is
coming to India and then they're a cricket
player.
We're like,
let them come now these Indian cons are
the last World Cup champions and we're
ready to fuck Pakistan in the ass. Get
what happened. Guess what happened?
They got fucked big time now everything
else in Pakistan is shit as you must
know. Just do this man.
Wow. This guy, you know,
he is writing his second language here.
Just do this man and be on
my fucking side. All right.
As I approach you first.
All right. Come on man.
Just tell these Indian read these things
first before you just start reading.
That's what makes it good.
Just tell these Indian cons how
bad their cricket team sucks. Oh,
and they can eat a dick.
Oh,
some other clever shit that he say he
wants you to trash Indian way cause he's
back as Danny and they have a cricket
feud as well. Please rape them.
Woo. Please rape them. Yeah Sir.
Don't use that word like that.
Oh, you know what? You don't understand
sports. How'd you like? Dang God.
You thought you were going
to beat Pakistan Woo.
Where the defendant fucking champions
with our fraternity paddles hitting that
racket ball around the circular field.
Well guess what? You fucking lost.
You would think considering all
you guys have 18 fucking kids,
you could find a couple of Jordans in
there. Right? And you could repeat,
oh well you know what? I
think next year, Pakistan,
you guys should play again and
winner takes all of cashmere.
What do you think about that? And you
get all the other side's tanks go.
How was that? Was that all right? Like,
all right, cool. Thank you for that.
Let me go.
This is Belper.
This was bill burr trashing anybody else?
If you watch obscure sports
aisle and you guys win a game,
I'll talk trash about the other fucking
person not knowing anything about,
I don't even know.
I don't even get the game I liked for it.
You know what I like about
cricket though is how long it is.
You know when you drink this, this certain
sports that you just going to love,
you just the, there's a cricket game
that people like drink out like that.
It doesn't seem like, it seems more
civilized in that for some reason. Why?
I don't know why because it's foreign.
Wow. Cause it's nowhere like all white.
They just looked like spiffier. I Dunno.
They just looks like there's
some sort of class element.
Do you think it about Polo? No. Don't
they were all way. I don't know.
Pull up. Pull up an image
of people playing cricket.
I'm pretty sure everyone gets secretary.
Everyone wears white.
Well you have the laptop in front of you.
I got, I got nothing. Oh listen, this,
this is, this is why, of course
they drink. They probably have,
they probably have hooligans.
You sit in the same,
you think it's sophisticated after
what this guy wrote, faggot. Cont rape.
That's all. That's one. That's all
in there. It isn't. That's crickets.
Vance for you. Oh, that's not
cricket fans. You know what that is?
That sports fifth, that sports fans. We're
morons. Yeah, but I think that more like,
like something like a rugby,
I feel like has more of a
hooliganism attached to it.
I feel like cricket is more like, hello.
You know what? We're going into the creek.
Have you ever met a professional boxer
or aura or one of those UFC guys?
I guess so. If you meet them.
Most of them, yeah. Most of them.
They're really just mellow. Sure.
They don't need to prove anything.
Right. You know what I mean? Maybe
it's the fan. So you're aware.
We are not talking about
the rugby players. Maybe the
fans are more, I don't know.
I, you know, I have no idea.
I can tell you right now,
I would keep my fucking mouth shut if I
ever went to any sort of sporting event
in another country. Unless, you know
when I go to Canada it's hockey.
I know hockey's backed by the way.
I'm really excited that it's back great.
All is forgiven.
I don't give a fuck.
I've accepted it that it's a part of
hockey every fucking five, six years.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I know you don't usually eat it all is
forgiven. What's forgiven the strike?
They went on strike.
Oh you noticed you've been able to watch
way more real housewives this time this
year.
You notice I'm watching way more hoop and
then if somehow in a fucking secretive
way become a Knicks fan because they
never show the Celtics cause we stink.
So they're always showing the Knicks and
I, I just, I'd love their team. Okay.
I fucking love their team.
Did you see that? Jr Smith's,
that donkey had on that alleyoop with
the guy threw a too low and he caught it
down by his nuts and just with
one hand just fucking threw it.
There was one of the most
vicious things I've ever seen,
even probably as vicious is that baboons
snapping that restless neck back in the
fifties. Um, alright.
Innocent deer in headlights.
Hey Bill. Loved the show. I'll start
from the beginning but I'll be quick.
I know people,
you know I can't read so let's just
get right to the fucking point. Yeah.
Did you had, did you ever read aloud
in class? I hated it. I hated it.
I would be like trying to count ahead
how many people and then try to guess
which paragraph and I would always start
looking over it before he got to it.
Do you know when I was
in the fourth grade,
one time I had to read out loud and I
got in my head and I was like going like,
I'll just read the first couple
sentences too. I did it. I was like,
love the show.
I'll start from the,
and I finished it, I finished it.
I wasn't baby, I wasn't a bit,
I was in fourth grade, I should have
been able to read shit had bill.
So when I finished reading the paragraph,
the teacher went like before, you know,
I was like,
I was so fucking relieved that it was
over and I was just waiting for her to
call and the girl sitting
behind me for her, you know,
Jennifer read the next paragraph and when
I finished there was this silence and
then the teacher said, I didn't
understand one word. He said,
oh, anybody else understand
what he saw? No, nobody said.
She made me go back and
reread it. I love the show.
I'm like choking back tears
hoes though from the beginning.
Cause back in the 70s when you could
be mean to people. Oh that's terrible.
Or is he too fucking stupid?
Be in this grade.
You poor thing. That's not nice. It's
not nice. It's fucking hilarious.
I stunk at it and she called
me out on it and I deserved it.
What I should've done was viewed as a
challenge and gone home and just walked
around the house reading out loud.
Well, you're in fourth grade,
your brain doesn't work like that.
Listen,
you're never too young
to start manning up.
Instead.
I accepted defeat and I,
I dunno,
I know I never got that.
Two things happen to me that
year that were fucking brutal.
They had the reading out loud
and getting trashed for it
and then they did this thing called,
was it called a sound spelling.
Okay.
You know, you learn how to
read in fourth grade. Yeah.
You progress in the second grade.
You learn how to spell and all that,
all that shit first, second, third.
Okay. It's still fresh in your head.
Don't take it out of the oven.
It's still all doughy.
So you know what these fucking idiots do.
They introduce sound spelling in
the fourth grade and it's basically,
uh, I guess phonetic spelling
is what it properly proper name.
Will you spell cat k a t.
And they started going through all of
these words that I just learned how to
spell within the last couple
of months to couple of years.
And they started putting case where
there was cs and all this shit.
And I never recovered. Never recovered.
Why would they do that though?
Why would they? Because
somebody's, I don't get to,
they thought that it would help
with something. Why would they,
why would they do that?
Why would they put fluoride in toothpaste?
Why would they do that when it slows your
brain down and it makes you just kind
of, you know, hey man,
dreams aren't coming true.
But however I look at these
white teeth, you know, uh,
I don't know what I'm talking about ever.
Just know that.
Know that about this podcast. I don't
know what I'm talking about. Ever.
The Monday morning podcast, that's
your tag. That's it. Alright.
Innocent deer in the headlights. All
right. Push away that fourth grade.
Do you want me to read it for you?
Hey,
if that guy who played Darth Vader's
voice can get over stuttering,
I can do this. All right. Hey, bill loved
the show. I'll start from the beginning.
I'll be quick.
I'm about to graduate college.
I met a lady in one of my classes.
We talked throughout the semester.
Ah,
dude.
How many times was the moment to get a
number coming and going and you were like,
fuck. Um, and on the last day of
class she offered me or number.
There it is. She was, why we
rolling her eyes the whole semester,
like for the love of God.
Do I gotta drop to my knees?
Um,
where the hell am I?
She came up to,
I know.
Oh. Oh Billy. Oh, Villi. Amanda Class.
We talked.
What the fuck was I?
I thought she was having
a flashback right now.
Did I just make that part
of it if I can't find it,
I met a girl, one of my class we talked
throughout this semester. Last Day class.
She asked me a number.
I thought she was pretty cool and when,
and went out with her later that week.
She came up. No, she came and met me.
She came in right.
Met Up with me on, this is
fucking torture. Just read.
Oh my God.
They met up with me and my friends is
that a bar brings went well and we
ended up going back to my place.
Oh Gee,
here's,
we start fooling around on the couch and
then she gets up and guides me into my
room and I was getting nervous because
I haven't been with many girls and not
entirely sure what to do
in this situation. Um,
she strips naked and while
we are sitting on my bed,
she opens her legs to reveal a
white string coming out of her lady.
Enos guys with the gross details here.
I wasn't really sure what it was at the
time. Oh, this guy's, he's a fucking,
he's like that. He's like that little
fat rabbit sitting outside the, uh,
the apartment complex. He
didn't know what it was. Well,
maybe he was just so disoriented that he
just was like, what is good? There's no,
there's nothing in a guy's
upbringing that says, uh, you know,
tells you about the rip cord. You know,
that's just something you just learned.
It's one of the few things like,
you know,
back in the day on his toes to learn
about like the whole reproductive system.
It's literally like half an hour,
not even half an hour.
Maybe it's a 10 minute part of your
lesson about the reproductive system when
they, if they, if they didn't have that,
they didn't have that
when I was growing up.
But I can guarantee you in those
classes, they never say, hey,
and if you ever time to bang some chick
who's on the rag, right, right. Of course,
if you see that little string coming out,
uh,
that means you've trying to bang
girl and turns out she's on the rag.
You know why? But the thing is she knows
she's having her period. So why is,
she won't read the, we know what she's
gonna do. She's gonna want to eat,
she's going to want a bang and say it's
not a heavy flow day or she's going to
take it in there. Oh yeah. That's that.
That could be alright. Let's
just, this is getting gross.
This is like really graphic,
very graphic because I wasn't
really sure what it was at the time.
I would have loved if you said
what you thought it might be.
Ah, she flossing down there. Um,
I told her exactly what I
was thinking and he said,
this is what he said.
This is classic. He sees,
she said that naked with the legs spread
and he goes, there's a white thing.
Dot Dot.
Dot.
There.
She told me that it was a Tan Tampon.
Yeah.
And that she was on her period. She said
it was fine in still wanted to have sex.
I got really weirded out, not grossed
out. I got really weirded out.
So I told her that maybe we should wait.
She told me there are
other ways I called it a,
I was still, or maybe even
further freaked out by this girl.
So we just went to sleep.
Keep in mind that this,
this is the first night we ever hung out.
Yeah. Why did you let her stay there?
Did I do the right thing? Should I
meet up with her again or is she crazy?
I don't, I don't understand.
It's a lot. And Go fuck
yourself. What? Ha, I'm confused.
Did I do the right thing by
not sleeping with her? Yeah.
By not having anal sex
with her or whatever,
or just plowing through the fucking storm.
If you didn't feel comfortable fetus,
it'd be, didn't feel comfortable with it,
then you shouldn't have such thing.
A captain on a ship.
I just going through the wave
captain,
you're crazy. Well, I
got him back a Jeff Fag.
I'm sorry you put that word in my head.
Who did that fucking guy over there?
Yeah.
Never say the f word. I say,
fuck, I don't say faggot.
I've tried to take it out. They
took, they told me to knock it off.
I respect it. You, you do knock it
off. So I said, right. Yeah. You know,
I'm not trying to be a dick here,
but for the longest time you called
somebody effect. It had nothing to do.
It just meant you were a pussy.
We didn't know what he was saying.
I know that you fucking faggot.
We get it. I'm just saying.
So anyways,
Bill bird trying to knock it off.
I'm trying,
the thing is you're so
sometimes you're so,
I don't know of innocence,
the right word,
but sometimes you are you going
to say hope you're still, yeah.
You're so dumb about the, like you'd
be offensiveness that you grew up with.
You're always like what everybody says,
you're so defensive about it
for so long. Yeah. But you know,
cause it's like you honestly don't
know any better cause you're, yeah,
you're dumb.
And then finally enough people explain
it to you that you are a human being.
You have a heart and you're a sensitive.
So you're like, oh, okay. Right.
I won't say it anymore.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Like the attitude you have about it.
It's like you want to be a good person,
but you're like,
you're angry that you have to like,
let go of this part of your past where
people just said Sag to each other.
And it was like, hey, that's what
we say. It's Boston and go fucking,
well, you know, Jimmy Dore,
the great Jimmy Dore actually
did his show, uh, um,
Friday night and he's so God damn funny,
he has the funniest fucking
bit on that on knock it off.
Why that's a dumb ad campaign
because it really is like,
you know, hey, knock it us really like
this parental, I don't know. I don't,
we'll saying, oh that's gay
or stuff like that. Yeah.
He's not saying that that's wrong to
try and get people to stop doing it,
but is that the best way to get people
to stop doing it by saying, hey,
knock it off. Like you're driving
the car and you're their parent,
you're swinging it. They're like, I
don't want to step on his bid. Here. Go,
go see Jimmy Dor and request that bit.
Um,
so anyway,
this young man is things that I do the
right thing by not sleeping with her.
And should I see her
again because he knows
so loose free 100%.
If she wanted to have
straight up vaginal sex,
there was not a condom thick enough or
all encompassing that would have to take
up. Like you'd have to
put it on like underwear,
that condom and boxer underwear
and then have to all be rubber.
You'd have to put on basically a wetsuit
that had like a little flappy thing,
therefore your deck.
So you did the right thing.
And he was talking about he would not
have felt comfortable having sex with this
girl while she said he,
if he already was thrown off by
the fact that she had a Tampon.
And if you know this girl is a pig,
why is she a pig?
Because you don't defend her
just because she's a woman. Um,
and I'm asking a question.
I'm, I'm defending the a pig.
What she's paying from her private
parts. Yeah. And just, it's just like,
let's fucking have at it.
That is some fucking truck stop
large Marge shit. All right,
give me a fucking break.
I'm not trashing all woman women.
Woman here is a pig.
He probably no protection.
Oh Ko k could have gone in the back
door with this girl first fucking day.
She's a pig.
So what use are you feel like she wasn't
ladylike and respecting herself enough
or something?
This is what I'm thinking.
You ever see the club everybody wants to
go to when there's that long line down
the street? Yeah. That's what
has been lining up to her.
Her fucking private parts ever
heard of the term slut shaming?
Have you heard this term that people,
is it something else?
Well that's one I've never used so I
don't need to knock that off. I've never
knock it off. But have you heard of slut
shaming? Which is no, but I can, I can.
I can guess what it is.
How
good of a woman does it.
She's a whore. Right?
Exactly. And that's the truest thing
you'll ever fucking read. Okay.
What is the truest thing that if
a woman does it, she is a whore.
So you believe in that whole double
standard abso-fucking-lutely why is that
exactly? Because you, there's,
there's no skill involved with you guys
getting laid. All you have to do, hey,
is this is a skill based
thing and what defines skill?
The skills that you feel
like you're presenting it.
You're getting laid as a guy.
Tell me all about your amazing skills
that are you done? Are you done?
Oh yeah. For now. Then we've
already had this argument. Yes.
We talked about it in a bar one time
and I said, okay, let's turn the tables.
All right,
let's pretend that I'm holding the
fucking bag of gold and you're calming and
trying to get it. Okay. Hit on me.
Come, come, go do it right now. Right?
Right now I give good. Thank you. Oh No,
I'm not good at it. I'm not coaching.
You know why? Why? Because it's a
skill. When women sit there and they go,
oh my God, guys come up to me and they
say that Donald stuff and it's all,
that's all you have to say as a guy.
Oh yeah. What would you say? Go ahead.
Dazzle me. Come up me with your, hey
baby, what's your sign fucking line?
What do you got convinced
me? Hey, uh, exactly.
Exactly. We have to convince
people on stage late at night.
And I thought you were pretty funny.
Oh thanks
sue. Yeah, and I'll be, I'll be,
I'll be the girl who's going to
deliberately make it difficult. I'm not,
and I'm not good at it. You know I'm not
good at hitting on people. That's not my,
and you know why that is nice because
you didn't have to do is put on a
spaghetti strap dress. It'd be
like, Ooh, did I drop a Napkin?
And you're in the game flirting.
I can do. But that's different.
That's more like conversational.
But no,
I'm not going to just walk up
to understand that as a guy,
you have to convince a woman to have
sex with you with after you've convinced
her, you have to continue convincing her.
It's all the way back to the apartment.
You got to keep the plates spinning and
any little fucking thing can throw it
off. Okay. So because of,
because of that whole struggle that you
pour men have to do in order to get a
woman to sleep with you,
I feel bad for you. Okay.
So because there is that difference,
then just no respect.
And then I suppose that makes it
okay to say, if a girl is like, hey,
let's just, you know, I want to have
fun with you. Let's let's have sex.
All of a sudden she's a
slut or a pig and all that,
and the guy is like, what the hero or
the more skilled of the two of them.
It doesn't make any sense.
I get done Nia
[inaudible] fucking date. She's sitting
there, okay, she wants to have sex,
whatever.
But you're sitting there with a fucking
bloody rag hanging out of you and you
don't even know this guy and you just
fucking spread your fucking legs.
And he's like, ah, yeah, there's a thing
hanging out of there. And she says,
there's other ways. I guarantee you, you
know what that girl is? That's the girl.
When you take out the condom, who
goes, ah, God, I hate condoms.
That fucking girl you ever girl ever says,
God,
I hate condoms. Immediately run the
other direction. Go in the bathroom,
rub one out. Get that dumb idea
out of your fucking head. God,
I hate condoms. Run the other way too
to keep it fair. No, you're right.
You're so into women's issues right now.
You can't see the trees through the
forest and this guy was a fucking pig. No,
I mean I know I definitely,
you're right.
A girl who has got a Tampon and who's
spreading her legs and being like, Hey,
and the guy was like, ah, are you one your
what's going on there? And she's like,
hey, there's other ways to do it. Ways.
I mean, I haven't got any friends.
I guess there's like smoother ways to,
I don't have this guy.
I would never do that.
I admit that.
But I'm not necessarily throwing all bad
judgment behind this girl because maybe
she was just drunk and she
was probably like, Oh shit,
I'm on my period is a babe in the woods.
He could've been at this point with
her after his first class. Okay.
He hasn't been with a lot of girls.
He basically is like,
do you ever see that video of
those guys who put put a goat in a,
in a fucking cage with a python and
it doesn't even know it was horrible.
They didn't think that it,
the goat didn't even know what it was.
The fucking snakes like Oh shit.
Literally and like lick the fucking
pythons face kind of freak the thing out.
Like Whoa, what was that?
And then all of a sudden,
by the time it realizes what it's
in the cage with, it's fucking over.
So terrible. So this guy is the goat
and this girl is pot. It's a snake.
And he doesn't realize what he's saying.
And just by the doubt and the snake,
by dumb luck,
she went to strike and he fucking shook
it like the fucking head was turning
into a parable. The goat in the
snake. Well, all right. So basically,
clearly this girl has a little too,
is on a different level than this guy.
And perhaps he should maybe find a girl
that's probably is at some point of life
is going to have the STD
fun pack. You know, what's,
what's included in that front
pack? A little, well, gonorrhea,
probably some crabs. The starter
kit, the starter kit, you know,
before you move on to the more serious
shit like Bola herps is forever.
So that's pretty interesting.
I would think.
That sounds like an advertising campaign
for herpes forever. It's forever.
Herps purpose forever.
But don't they have like a,
they have like that medicine you can
take and keep it at bay. Uh, yeah.
That's what they say in the commercials
I like. And if you have an outbreak,
take more or whatever. I Dunno. I
Dunno what they tell you to do that.
That coke commercial. It
just scary. It's just like,
you know that just because you've taken
this and you don't have an outbreak
doesn't mean you can't spread it.
Right.
Do you know how happy that
makes me feel to be with you?
That we don't have the herb but we don't
have the Herp I don't have to worry
about that. It's forever. Right.
Those things. What I was single,
they scared the fucking shit out of me
and I remember then I hear stuff like,
even if you wear a condom, that's
not 100% I was just, Oh my God,
okay.
Yeah. I go, yes, she's on
my fingers. She's, she's a,
and this is not, it doesn't seem
like this is the girl for you.
She might be a little too advanced.
Will you stop alligator Armand it,
this might not be the girl for you.
She's a little too advanced.
This woman is a fucking war pig.
Your House eight arm and not,
I'm trying to be like tender and you know,
Nice.
You know what alligator arms means?
You don't watch sports. Now I don't.
You know what?
I really don't appreciate when I come
down here and having this conversation
with you and you want to
throw these little sports
things that me and you always,
you always say, oh, you don't want sports.
Oh, you didn't get the sports they like,
you'd have to like remind me that I'm
not on the same level as you like,
so I'm not going to get all your amazing
sports references and terms and phrases
and I don't appreciate that.
Can you guys believe that?
Went in 10 minutes of just going on
this rant about how dumb I am and how
innocent I am with using
the word fag and I,
I don't mean you have like an innocent
heart, but you're dumb and you're,
you just respond with rage the whole way.
You made me this fucking like simpleton.
You'd be doing everything but fucking,
you know, being in a big goof
like, hey, what are you doing?
Look walking on the street like you don't
want accidentally crushed somebody to
death trying to hug them. That's how
you just painted me. You're like, yeah,
you're like of a, of mice and men.
That's how you're painting me.
Within 10 minutes of this, you're Lenny
and of mice and men. That's how you do.
Yeah,
that's exactly how you described me.
I'm too dumb to know that
fucking reference cause I,
I see alligator arm is okay. You've
seen an alligator, right? Yeah.
Do they have long arms now?
They do not. They do not. And
it's basically it's a, uh,
it's a sports term.
MMM.
Somebody throws you the ball and you
could actually reach out and get it,
but you don't totally reach out cause
you're worried about getting hit. Okay.
Sort of Alex. So you
alligator arms. It's like Ah,
so and if you don't catch the ball, the
guy can't hit you. Oh okay. I thought so.
I'm saying so your alligator arm
and this and that, you're going,
this girl isn't the girl for
you, but blah blah blah. He's,
he's in there with the fucking pit viper.
Right.
He's the goat and she's the PS.
He is the STD free goat and he is
walking into a fucking Beta of just,
I mean,
I mean this girl probably I want to get
it to is just fucking just off for you.
She's not the girl for you. That's bad
advice. Why this girl, I'm telling you,
you fucking pig.
And you'd have to suppose to do about it.
Tell the whole fucking school
she's not the girl for you.
Move on to somebody else's more
your speed. Why is that bad advice?
Because you're acting like, you
know, she's not into sports,
likes to eat and as a morning person,
he likes sports and staying up. You know
what? This person isn't like, you know,
this person isn't for you. I
meant as like a foodie. It's like,
it's a simple way of saying that
you know you should move on. That's,
that's all it is.
No,
it's like you're sitting there with the
toddler and he's about ready to touch a
hot stove. You got to be like, there
has to be a sense of urgency here. Like,
like, no, no, no, no, no. This, this
will hurt you as well. Hope you know,
you make that little fucking can.
They don't even speak English.
You're trying to fucking, and
they can't, they can't speak yet.
You're trying to fucking fuck.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You're sitting there talking
to this person like, um, hey,
try some of this sandwich. Yeah, I
didn't really like that bread. Well,
maybe you'll like this bread like it,
like it's just like this whimsical.
There's too many Daisy's and
what you're saying, this is,
this is a very dangerous situation.
This guy should stay away from this girl
on all fucking and all girls like this.
She's got a, she's on her period and
she has no fucking like, like class.
She has opened so leg,
like what was he supposed to do?
Pull it out and just go off on it.
There's other ways she suggesting anal.
This girl is like up. She's a fucking
mess. Stay away from this girl.
This girl get pregnant.
This girl will give you a fucking disease.
This girl was steal your laptop
girls a fucking nightmare.
Knock it off. All right. All
right. Advice for a lady.
Dear Bill, I've been with my
boyfriend for two years now.
We're in college together
and he's currently taking a
semester abroad. Oh Jesus.
Where in Brazil.
Before he left,
we had a running joke that I was going
to need a vibrator when he left as a
surprise party gift.
He got me one.
I have a couple of friends whose
boyfriends bought them sex toys.
So while I was a little surprised,
he actually got me a vibrator.
I also happen to know that
it's a relatively normal,
it's relatively normal for a
boyfriend and do that. Yeah.
That's basically like this
era's chastity belt. You know,
you're trying to lock down the
pussy. That's disgusting. Yeah. That,
but that's what he's doing now anyway.
Yeah.
But it's done because those
things are used them too much.
They numb up your area there and then
the guy can't even remotely try and,
you know,
do something for it.
And then you gotta be
sitting there banging,
banging them as their user are
using the thing. As, you know,
it's like you want an alien,
a fucking this girl
that's just all dick has no
body. All right, whatever.
Let's move on one of the base.
Pay Some of my fucking life.
I did live a little bit of a life before
I met you. I realize that any way,
fast forward to about a week
ago, we were on Skype. Uh,
he asks you to take this thing out. Um,
no, we don't have sex chats. Thank God.
And he casually asked me how
his gift for me was working out.
I told them it was
working out pretty well.
He then mentioned that he had
bought something for himself,
a fleshlight
Joe Rogan experience is brought to
you by the fleshlight every week.
He does a very weird,
those are very rare.
Weird fucking okay.
They look like that thing.
Boba Fett I fell into when he died
and one of those space movies. Okay.
Wow. Um, I knew how to be faithful
to right. That's nice. Okay.
He said,
she goes,
I knew what this was because I am an
avid listener of Joe Rogan's podcast.
How you doing?
Joe Rogan's come up three times in this
podcast who raves about it constantly.
My boyfriend had never mentioned to me
that he was interested in anything like
that and I always thought the
idea of it was totally creepy.
I acted like it was totally cool,
but in all honesty,
I really don't want him to be
fucking a perfect fake wait,
I got lost in that.
I actually was thinking as Joe going
to get mad that I'm saying that this is
weird. Okay. I acted like it was
totally cool, but in all honesty,
I really don't want him to be fucking
of perfect fake vagina whenever he wants
to.
I'm finding myself getting crazy jealous
and angry whenever I think about it.
I know, I know I'm jealous of an
inanimate object, which seems insane.
Let me finish.
I'm really struggling with this because
part of me wants to be completely okay
with it since it's sort of a hypocrite.
It's sort of hypocritical to get
angry when he got me a vibrator.
But now I'm starting to think that maybe
he only bought me a Dildo so I wouldn't
be able to complete when he
got himself a proxy pussy,
Pussy.
So what do you think?
Do I need to suck it up and get over
this or is my jealousy legitimate?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um, go fuck is fake pussy. As long
as he's not faking a real pussy.
I mean fucking a real policy and
then you know, it's all good.
Plus you, you, it's not just
like the, the pussy that it's,
that he's missing. He's
also missing like, you know,
you're touching and kissing and
the whole other part of it too.
And that fake pussy cat low.
Am I there? No, he isn't.
He's getting right to the dessert.
Don't be jealous. Tried these
Brussels sprouts. Don't need them.
Don't be jealous.
I bring over the trace late shea,
when he comes back it will be even better
because you both have been like doing
it with inanimate objects and so I don't
to be rediscovering each other all over
again. I'll be even better. I
don't think. They don't even worry.
I don't think it's a good thing.
Why?
Because uh,
once you start down a path sexually,
you know,
in order to get off that path, you
don't just jump over onto another path.
You got to walk all the way
back up the path you went down,
get to the fork where you fucked up
and then head down the other one.
What I'm saying is he might get used to
just doing that and this sensation of
that is what gets him off. And then when
her pussy doesn't feel like fleshlight,
he'll, he'll, he'll
build bang her and then,
and then when he needs to
finish, he'll be like, all right,
and now for me and what that fucking thing
better. If anything,
he'll be like, oh my God,
I forgot what a real woman feels like
and he'll be done in like two minutes.
What's your hope?
Um,
I don't think she should be
jealous of it though. They're both,
they're both doing the right thing when
you're in a relationship and you're that
far apart from each other because he did
bang all sorts of Harry European girls,
no offense to hear European girls,
but I'm just saying, you know, well
listen, I watched this thing one time
or listen to it on the radio, uh,
one of those call sex shows
and this guy had a pull away.
He jerked off cause he dry hump the rug.
It was causing like chafing on
his dick and it, but it, it,
it was the only way he could get off
because he wasn't in a relationship for a
while and he kept doing that and I dunno.
So I'm just saying like I would go
easy on those. It's like anything,
anything in moderation.
How often is he using this and
how often is she using that?
If you use a vibrating too much,
you numb yourself up down there.
And then when you guys down there
that he can't feel anything.
It's so disgusting. Um, overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Overrated.
The Superbowl,
underrated rounds one and two
of the NFL playoffs build.
This may be sacrilegious
to say in America,
but I actually enjoy rounds one and
two of the NFL playoffs more than the
Superbowl.
That is a sector religious because at no
point is beyond say or Brittany Spears
sing before and in the
halftime show there's not a
bunch of douchebags who don't
like football showing up feeling
like they have to be there. You know,
all the broads. Why did you look?
Yeah, why are you looking at me?
Cause you go to super bowl parties
every year and you hate football. Yeah.
Well they're fun. They're nice
gatherings. Talk when the game's on. No,
I don't run. Yap. When the
most important game is on,
it's disgusting.
If you do it again this
year we're breaking up each
week you get two games both
on Saturday and Sunday. There seems
to be that we can win this thing,
excitement in the air and I can relax
and watch the games and the comfort of my
home or at a local bar without dozens
of non-fans in the room as is typically
the case of the Superbowl party Superbowl
and the other hand has become so
pretentious in recent years.
I don't even really want to get
worked up for it as much as I used to.
The game takes forever.
85% of the commercial sucks and we're
forced to stare at Madonna's beat up face
for 30 minutes during a halftime show
plus the two week gap in between the
Superbowl and the conference champion
really takes the air out of the sales.
What are your thoughts?
I think this is what you do.
You watch the Superbowl alone and you
tape it and you start watching it,
you DVR it and you watch,
you let you let you give the
game a 90 minute headstart
and then then you just sit down,
you watch it by yourself and you plow
through the pregame and you just watch the
fucking game and when
the halftime show comes,
you fast forward through that and now
you're under the third quarter and third
quarter and fourth quarter it's
going to be regular time football.
That's the way to watch the Superbowl
and you watch it by yourself.
Maybe with another buddy of
yours who that enjoys the game.
That's how I would do it.
You know?
No thoughts on that? No. But
what about the social aspects?
You're going to have brownies
during the oak cheese doodles.
Oh my God.
The way the broads talked to her and
that fucking game and then and then and
it's true. Shuts up to watch
the commercials and then,
and then the game comes back on. The
third one was late. What did you think?
Well that's definitely the best one
so far. How much did that cost? Well,
why don't you stop going to the
Superbowl parties, Matt and bill,
why don't you stop if you don't like
the game. I don't do any of that.
So that you're talking about,
I don't, I don't like needles.
I don't go to your fucking
metapoint party book. Two needles.
They don't do anything. What
do you do? Arts and crafts.
I don't crash the Superbowl or those
things and come there and talk when you're
trying to glue the popsicle sticks
together and then shut the fuck up.
When a talk throughout the game,
I go in the other room or I hang out
with other people if they're lies. Lies,
lies. Yeah. That's the
Monday morning podcast.
Oh, before I get outta here.
Oh, that's it. That's it.
Where he did a nice long one.
All right. No. Okay.
Um, amazon.com everybody,
if you want to, um,
if you want to buy something on
amazon.com and support my podcast,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on the
podcast page. Take it. We've got to link.
Um, what would it be called? The little
box. A little window thing. The little,
a little icon. You Click on that thing.
I have no idea what they're called.
Banner ad.
You Click on it,
you go to amazon.com you buy something
and they kicked me back a little bit of
money. I take 10% of that and I throw
it to the wounded warriors project. You,
you sponsored this and the wounded
warriors. See that's it. Everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. And uh, yeah.
You ever get with a girl?
And she spreads her leg with the,
the rip cord there. All right. You're the,
she's a snake. Get the fuck
out of the cage. See you.